CJ
future
China is on fire right now
[Applause]
what you're seeing right now is the
biggest Uprising in China that we've
seen in a very long time
[Music]
that's because in China protesting
against the CCP is punishable by life in
prison
and sometimes even death
people regularly disappear in China for
going up against the governments but
right now people all across China are
standing up in a rare Act of defiance in
fact this is the biggest Mass protest
since Tiananmen Square
oh
and it's all because they've had enough
of this China's zero covet policy has
pushed Society to the Limit and that's
because so many of the zero covered
policies are excessive inhumane or just
plain stupid but for people to
understand how strict this covid
Crackdown has been I've been talking to
people who have family in China talking
about throughout the level of people not
being able to move one of my friends was
locked in his apartment for 90 days yeah
so you're not allowed out of his
apartment except for testing for 90 days
if you we know people starve to death
yeah in Shanghai I don't care what your
culture is or what your religion is or
where you're from but the idea of having
your child your toddler taken away from
you yes to a quarantine Camp yes
um is absolutely appalling yes freedom
Freedom subscribe for more and this is
the Revolution Brewing in China
[Applause]
[Music]
and really fast if you have your own
business and you're still doing
everything yourself stop being a one-man
Army it's time to start Outsourcing some
of your work so you can focus on the
things you're best at the problem is
outsourcing is tough and expensive it
typically costs four thousand dollars to
hire a new employee you gotta sort
through candidates find the right person
handle payroll raises vacation days it's
just a hassle that's why you gotta check
out business rocket business rocket is a
subscription service that allows you to
get unlimited graphic design social
media marketing virtual assistant and
software development from a full-time
local employee for as low as 99 a month
that's why a full-time employee for as
low as 99 a month for example let's say
you need some graphic design you could
go through the trouble of hiring a
designer yourself or you can just pay
139 a month for your own full-time
graphic designer on business rocket that
can do everything you need done in the
realm of graphic design
need a software developer they usually
cost over a hundred thousand dollars a
year but with business rocket you get
one for only 3.99 a month you also get
24 7 access to one of business Ruckus
project managers so whenever you need
any work done you simply tell them what
you need there's no commitments and you
can cancel at any time and they even
have a seven day free trial business
rocket makes these low prices possible
by economies of scale everyone who works
at business rocket gets paid a full-time
salary meaning their monthly costs are
fixed allowing business rocket to offer
the best price possible while giving you
guys the best quality possible stop
being a one-man Army and see for
yourself if this service is a good fit
for your business risk-free head to
businessrocket.il Jake Tran to sign up
today for your free 7-Day trial that's
businessrocket.io with the link below
thanks to business rocket for sponsoring
this video
foreign
[Music]
China incubates the virus that will
eventually spread across the world
so it's just about 3 A.M I've got my my
mask on in the midst of a rush that
essentially they are putting Wuhan the
city limits under a lockdown patience
by doctors in
suits pharmacies struggling to keep
masks on the shelves
the city of 11 million now halting all
public transportation and outbound
flights Hi how are you my name is Ben
Kavanagh I live in Wuhan and today I'm
going to go to the shop one mask
another mask apparently this mask
actually doesn't do much but two masks
is always better than one don't forget
the most important thing
and the silliest thing
February 2020 Wuhan and surrounding
provinces are first to implement
mandatory lockdowns you're gonna listen
to that important
drastic measures to Halt the spread of
that deadly virus Wuhan China ground
zero for the outbreak now under lockdown
China formally announces its now
Infamous zero covid policy with China's
CDC proclaiming that quote the current
strategic goal is to maintain no or
minimal indigenous transmission of SARS
cov2 until the population is protected
through immunization with safe and
effective covid-19 vaccines end quote
from there China and Xi Jinping would
stick to this zero covet policy no
matter the costs
December 2020 China announced that
China's sino-farm vaccine is approved
for use among the Chinese population
four months later the head of China's
CDC says that Chinese vaccines actually
don't work that well in fact they are
only 50 percent effective and this would
prove disastrous to the Chinese regime
China's top Disease Control official has
set the efficacy of the country's covert
vaccines is low light stage trials in
Brazil found coronavac produced by
Chinese companies synovac biotech has a
50 efficacy at preventing infection
compared to 76 percent for AstraZeneca
and 95 for Pfizer
other countries would also come to
similar conclusions which is why while
the rest of the world started opening up
China stayed under lockdown and this
Iron Fist policy continued to this day
Omicron breaching beijing's borders a
single case putting the Winter Olympics
host City on high alert China's zero
coped policy making no exceptions in the
capital city targeted lockdowns
immediately activated prompting
authorities there to order more rounds
of mass testing in Shanghai and Tianjin
millions of residents are also facing
prolonged lockdowns as the government
tries to Stamp Out new clusters China is
facing its worst outbreak of covet since
the start of the pandemic the country
reported more than 3 500 new cases on
Monday alone that's actually a very high
number for China this is one of the
testing centers in China here one of the
citizens was spent down to the ground
she was forced to take a Wuhan virus
test
foreign
living in post-pandemic China your life
is at the whim of an app a contact
tracing app if your code turns yellow
you may have to quarantine for a week
read two weeks if you're inside a
building where a covid case is detected
you will have to quarantine there you
will be locked in
you might get locked in your home
[Music]
the Chinese government officials now
installing fences in Shanghai blocking
people from leaving their homes the
extent of my freedom is all the way to
my Terrace door here we're lucky enough
to at least get some fresh air outside
our community volunteers sending me this
image of what's on the other side of our
door a freshly taped paper seal a
reminder not to leave some will be sent
to quarantine camps
I don't care what your culture is or
what your religion is or where you're
from but the idea of having your child
your toddler taken away from you yes to
a quarantine Camp yes
um is absolutely appalling and all you
can do is pray that your health code
doesn't turn red
evelopers
everything is getting tested for covid
cats crabs people's shoes and because
businesses are constantly shutting down
there isn't enough food to go around
foreign
people are literally starving to death
trapped inside their own homes
the Chinese government is concerned
about being overwhelmed uh with uh its
medical system having people dying in
the streets and for the first year the
population was docile they listened to
Daddy Xi Jinping they complied with
lockdown orders for the most part but
it's now near the end of 2022 the
Chinese people have been suffering
through this for around two years now
and it finally became too much
the footage you're watching right now is
of a burning Residential Building in
xinjiang and although we can't play the
audio to not get demonetized if you did
hear the audio you would hear the last
screams of the residence inside by the
way this is why you should click that
join button below to watch our
uncensored documentaries the other
residents could only stand by their
Windows to watch because all their doors
were locked shut including the doors of
the burning building
all to prevent the spread of covid this
event was the final straw the Chinese
people have had enough universities all
over the country started organizing a
mass protest by sharing images through
their own version of a Google doc they
gathered on campus grounds
in Shanghai a lot of people have already
been detained not only last night they
did it for everybody for all the people
for the delivery guys not to be locked
in their apartments for everybody to be
able to receive medicines and food we
need to help these people free those
people in Shanghai protests are not out
of the question in China but speaking
out against the CCP is all over the
country we're seeing different forms of
protest all against the government and
all against the lockdowns and it's
erupted into something that not even the
CCP can control many of the protesters
held up blank pieces of white paper when
men in Beijing told Reuters the white
paper represents everything we want to
say but cannot say this
is the stuff of Revolution moments like
these in history are the ones that lead
to leaders getting toppled regimes
getting overthrown and the Chinese
Communist party is doing everything in
their power to stop this uprising
[Music]
the Chinese government is getting
desperate they're doing everything they
can to change the narrative Anonymous
Twitter accounts are spamming the
protest Hashtags with useless images
mostly porn the police are deploying
signal Jammers so protesters can't post
videos online or communicate with each
other what you're seeing behind us here
is a signal jammer by the way this is in
rumchi they're sending signal Jammers
into places of protest in order to you
know stop people's cell phones so they
can't send messages they can't send
videos they can't you know contact each
other they can't coordinate that sort of
thing they're confiscating phones
they're literally blacking out messages
being sent through WeChat which is
China's version of Twitter people were
sending me pictures of their WeChat
moments all going black yeah all going
black there are moments in a moment it's
kind of like a tweet right let's just
say their tweets were all getting pulled
things got so bad that Daddy CCP went to
Apple and demanded they help quench the
fire so what did Apple do did they One
support free speech and the Chinese
people and give
ep the middle finger or two did Apple
instantly comply and limit their airdrop
feature on Chinese phones to prevent
protesters from sharing vital protest
information with each other without
relying on the internet we'll give you a
second to think this one through and if
you answered two apple instantly
complied with Daddy CCP you would be
correct earlier this month Apple did the
bidding of the Chinese government to
crush domestic protests against the
Communist party there Apple did this by
disabling its permanent airdrop feature
in China and so far only in China it's
the only country in which it's disabled
so why did Apple disable that feature in
China well because that feature
permanent airdrop allows iPhone users to
communicate directly with one another
without using the internet or cellular
networks both of which in a totalitarian
state like China are controlled by the
government and this is how the CEO of
Apple responded do you have any reaction
to the factory workers that were B eaten
and detained for protesting coveted
lockdowns
do you regret restricting airdrop access
that protesters used to evade
surveillance from the Chinese government
do you think it's problematic to do
business with the Communist Chinese
party when they suppress human rights
[Music]
history was left temporarily speechless
after being asked a question on the
protests given the widespread display of
anger and frustration at the zero
covered policy in recent days across
China
thinking about
if you're hoping
the last time there was a widespread
uprising like this was Tiananmen Square
back in 1989. how did that Uprising end
the Chinese government deployed troops
and tanks and it ended in a massacre and
guess what China doesn't want you to
know this but right now there are
already tanks driving down the streets
of Shanghai
[Music]
so one can only pray for the fate of
these Brave demonstrators
in the coming weeks the CCP will be
doing everything they can to hide what
they're doing to these protesters they
did this exact thing in the 70s when
they worked with China's private
hospitals to pull off one of the most
gruesome schemes in their history forced
organ harvesting where Chinese doctors
forcibly extracted organs from prisoners
to sell to Rich foreigners who are in
desperate need of an organ but if we go
into detail about this gruesome business
YouTube will definitely demonetize the
video which is why we decided to release
this as a full-length private
documentary only available to members of
this channel
all you have to do to get instant access
to the profitable business of forced
organ harvesting is to click that join
button below once you join you'll also
get access to tons of other
documentaries on topics like Jeffrey
Epstein MK Ultra CIA black sites all
things too controversial for a public
video and we release a new one every
month
and unlike University we're not going to
charge you thousands of dollars only to
leave you in the dark about how the
world really works you'll get all this
Insider knowledge they'll never teach
you anywhere else for just five dollars
a month and there's a refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships so if
you join and you don't think it's worth
it email us within your first month of
joining for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund so scroll down and click that
join button now
foreign
[Music]